kim kardashian's flying into her next
chapter like a champ
as her ex pete davidson seems to be in
good spirits overseas
you just gotta roll with it
in case you missed it keith is no more
but kim's got plenty to take her mind
off the split like this family vacation
in idaho
one more
yeah there's no shortage of activities
on this trip
kim documents their adventures on her
instagram story where ziplining appears
to be the fan favorite
and it's a good thing they captured it
for the gram as kim explains in this
caption quote my eyes were closed the
entire time so i'm so glad i have these
videos to see how pretty the scenery was
but hey fans know she's come a long way
since this classic moment in 2014.
take a deep breath
no no
let's go judge you could do it oh oh you
can't
[Music]
with this in mind maybe one day we'll
see kim give the treetop bridges another
go
ever again no one's ever talking me into
doing this again you hear me okay
but she does double down on her promise
writing quote i cried every step of the
way because i am so afraid of heights
but i did it and i promise i'm never
doing it again
but at least she fares a little better
on the water
[Music]
kim doesn't even seem to mind what she
calls quote after boat hair
she loves hair looks yeah
looking good in the great outdoors is
what kim does best
[Music]
meanwhile here's pete all smiles for the
cameras last week
he's been in australia for a project
and well
maybe distance didn't make the heart
grow fonder who are you texting ken does
his name rhyme with feet
following the split a source told us
quote pete being away for so long was
hard for them
but we can at least expect these two to
be friendly exes
pete is has got to be literally the best
human being i've ever met e.t source
noted quote kim celador is pete and will
always be friends with him
another source explained quote peta's
bummed things didn't work out with kim
but he is focused on the future in terms
of his career and personal life
he's just super genuine
and it's just really fun to just
hang out and do nothing and
watch tv and just do nothing
that's my favorite thing but now kim's
favorite things are family vacays and oh
yeah taking birthday shots with her
sisters
[Music]
wait what wait
[Music]